want a preview of the battle between
traditional cars and self-driving ones
don't look to Tesla Apple or Google look
back 100 years when automobiles took on
horses and the tars play dirty to win
massive holes who founded the olds Motor
Works Oldsmobile was particularly
aggressive in his attacks on the horse
this is like a psychologic thing I don't
know where would fall and diagnostic
something he really hated horses that's
G Wayne Miller he wrote car crazy a book
that's about the really early days of
cars and early car marketers had the
horse on their mind those cars were
unreliable and traveled on really bad
roads so car makers had a lot of work to
do and a lot of gimmicks that they use
people were scared of cars one
Undertaker used to leave his car on
automobile dashboards so automakers had
to be pretty aggressive selling their
invention they raced cars around the
country and manufacturers insulted their
competitors in ads but some of their
marketing firepower was reserved for the
horse of course they invented the term
horsepower to finding a car's power by
how many horses it could replace but
they also rigorously tested horse
braking power against their own cars
like a 15 horsepower Duty on inst a team
of horses
yeah the machine stopped more quickly
and they taunted mercilessly one old dad
said nature made a mistake in giving the
horse brain the company claimed cars
were cheaper and easier than horses
even though most cars were really pricey
and often required a home mechanic Henry
Ford hated horses to the horses doomed
Ford told a reporter these horses will
be driven from the land their troubles
will soon be over car makers took on
forces in public shame races and in 1895
a new magazine launched with a name that
was not subtle
it was the horseless age on the road
cars often collided into horses and
conflicts between car owners and farmers
were common but
on horses wasn't just personal it was
logical by the early 1900's the laboring
horse wasn't Noble it was a public
health hazard thousands of horses died
each year from disease overwork into old
age and those that lived produced
millions of pounds of manure those were
significant and real public health
hazards in urbanites were aware of it
too and cities like New York grew really
quickly streets became jammed with
horses and tons of horse waste and there
was another despicable downside not
every horse owner was a kind person and
so horses were frequently whipped and
beaten and when they died
you know these despicable owners often
would leave one ton or ten and a half
horse in the streets just leave it there
and that was a clear hell thousand cars
helped change that even horseless aged
spoke up for the horse saying in its
first issue that cars would spare the
obedient beasts so yes cars and horses
did have a knock-down drag-out fight but
there were two winners and that's how it
might be when self-driving cars come
around a fight to convince consumers
followed by a likely decrease in
fatalities and pollution it might not
always be easy motor world's 1905
headlines claimed that since time of
chariots people have opposed all new
vehicles and that might still be true
but as horseless age put it more sweetly
in their very first issue streets will
be cleaner jams and blockades less
likely to occur in accidents less
frequent
thanks to Dewayne Miller for talking to
me this video is basically a chapter of
his book and there are a lot of good
stories in there I wanted to share one
more insult however and it comes from
the first issue of the horseless age
this is what they said in response to
the argument that the automobile scares
horses suppose it does so two
locomotives bicycles streetcars fourth
of July celebrations and a dozen other
things horses must get used to it bone